[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everyone.
I'm Appie.
I have never talked
before in front of people.
So please forgive me
if this is really bad.
OK.
So I work at DeNA.
It's a Japanese company,
but we're growing
our global presence in gaming.
We had about $2 billion worth
of virtual currency spent
in our titles in Japan last
year, and around $270 million
spent around the
rest of the world.
So internally, we've
released a lot of titles.
And we just launched
"Blood Brothers 2"
in former San Francisco office.
We work with licensed IPs,
like Transformers, Star Wars,
Marvel.
I'm really excited
to mention we're
bringing over a huge hit in
Japan-- "Final Fantasy Record
Keeper."
It's made us around $10
million a month there,
so we're really
excited about it.
We track a lot of different
data in our games.
Of course, the standard KPIs
so we can compare our titles.
We get ad-vendor data and
do marketing analysis.
We also look at custom
game logs to tune
our games, improve our design.
So that leads to a lot of data.
On busy days, we get up to
60 megs of raw logs a minute
and around 50 gigs
of raw logs per day.
And that's given
us some headaches
in the past that I'll get into.
So all this data
that's coming from all
these different titles,
different studios,
we've been storing
in a Hadoop cluster.
That was our old solution.
Our version of Hadoop
is a little outdated.
But we've been
accessing it via HiveQL.
And last I checked, the
table we store that data
is around 42 terabytes.
This is a diagram of
our old infrastructure.
15 seconds and a slide
is not enough time
to describe all
these blank boxes.
But I will say that
as we've grown,
it's gotten more and
more complicated.
And we've had a lot of
bottlenecks and failure
points, the first of which is we
have a really slow ETL process.
From the point a player
triggers an action in our game
to when we would actually
be able to analyze
that data was about three
hours, sometimes more.
And we run a lot of live
events at our company.
So that made it really
hard to iterate quickly.
We've also grown our size quite
a bit in terms of the analysts
in our studio.
So we've clogged
our systems a lot,
time to time-- brought it down.
And it's been really hard
to control permissions
effectively, especially with
an older version of Hadoop.
And this is my
biggest pet peeve.
If I was trying to answer
some question with data--
running some query--
I would kick it off.
And then I'd wait,
and wait, and wait.
And it would take like
forever to get data back.
And you'd forget
what you were even
looking at when you started.
So our solution to deal
with all these issues
has been to just simplify
the common tech in our games
in the West.
We've done that by using
Google App Engine as a platform
server for our titles and to
use Google BigQuery for the data
storage and analysis.
So in terms of data ingestion,
it's become much quicker.
We've played around with
Google Streaming API
into BigQuery, cloud
logging, some other setups,
and we've managed to get the
time from users triggering data
to us being able to analyze
it down to seconds instead
of three hours.
We also have been able to
scale without any worries.
If we launch 10 more titles
or hire 10 more analysts,
we don't need to worry about
us bringing our systems down.
If something bad happens,
we just blame Google
and call them up--
[LAUGHTER]
--and sort it out.
And it's been really easy
to control permissions.
This was a huge headache before.
We work with a lot of
external developers.
And we couldn't effectively
share their own data back
to them.
And so now with just
a couple clicks,
we can share their
projects, their data
sets with people outside
and within our own studio.
And here I am running a query.
It's processing them
out-- 170 gigs of data,
grouping by a couple
things, coming up
with tutorial completion rate.
Took about eight
seconds in BigQuery--
the same query over less data in
Hadoop took about two minutes.
So lessons learned-- it hasn't
been totally smooth sailing,
mostly because we've had to
look at some things differently.
We've hit some quotas.
We have to work around a
different cost structure.
And it's a little bit
of a newer product,
so some features haven't
always worked as expected.
But Google has been great
with helping us with that.
So for us, it's really
been a good solution.
We want to be able to have
the control of our own data
in-house to do our own analysis.
And we don't want to have
to worry about maintaining
the actual infrastructure to
make that happen because we're
a games company, after all.
So I wanted to show you,
playing around with some data,
this is connected with Tableau.
And I'm diving into
an example of when
players were losing missions
early on in our game "Blood
Brothers 2."
We made a change, and
I wanted to drill in
by day to see if it worked.
And I can see here it did.
Here's another example.
We reduced the entry price
for a live event gotcha
that had unlocking steps.
And we increased
conversion early on,
though we decreased revenue
early in the funnel.
But overall, if you look at
the green line on the right,
we increased revenue compared
to other past events.
So at DeNA, we really try
to drive actions with data.
We prioritize our
engineering effort based off
of monitoring game performance.
We'll optimize our funnels.
We'll tune our games' economies.
And we iterate really
quickly on live events.
So in sum, BigQuery has
really helped us actually
focus on using this data instead
of just exhausting ourselves
trying to get to
the data itself.
So I'm excited to see what
our analysts at the company
push ourselves to now
that we have great tools.
And I'm glad I got to share
our experience with you today.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]